- [Interviewer] All right, Ke'.
Ke' where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I grew up in Inglewood, California.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood,
you had both your parents growing up?
- No, my father was arrested due
to murder when I was like 2 years old
and my mom got caught
up in the street life,
when I was around 5.
- [Interviewer] And who raised you?
- My grandmother.
- [Interviewer] Grandmother.
- Hmm.
- [Interviewer] How was
your childhood after all?
- It was pretty difficult
because I seen all the kids going
to school with parents
and I didn't have either.
All I had was my grandmother.
And later on down the line,
I ended up losing her.
So everything that seemed
like everything to me,
got taken away.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- 12.
- [Interviewer] So from
12 on where'd you go?
- I had to grow up pretty fast.
I went with my other grandmother,
which there was always a question
as if I belong to this family or not.
And it was kind of hurtful
'cause I felt like the
black sheep of the family.
So I got pushed away from them too.
And I ended up doing a lot
of crazy things in life.
I started prostituting, selling drugs.
I had kids at a very young age.
- [Interviewer] Where did
you start working the street?
- I actually started
working on Fig in 95th.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- At 18.
- [Interviewer] 18?
- Yes, 18 Fig in 95th was the first street
I ever got down on.
It was one of the most
terrifying nights of my life.
I was told all these things
to do and what not to do.
And I was so scared.
I don't know what to do if
somebody might kidnap me,
kill me, but I ran with it ,because it was
the only way that I could
find a source of income.
- [Interviewer] Did you have a pimp?
- Yes, I did.
- [Interviewer] How did he treat you?
- Actually, every guy that I've dealt
with in that line of work, were more so
in love with me versus trying to pit me.
So it was, I did it by choice
but not because he forced me to.
And any man that I dealt
with in that field had their own hustle,
meaning they were drug dealers
or had jobs to where it was both 50-50.
We both bringing something to the table,
but I had my fair share
off some that were kind of
crazy, that were abusive.
That took all my money.
That would leave me out all night.
And they went and just
spent money on cars, chains,
and other women.
While I worked hard for
it, it was pretty painful,
but eventually you grow after it.
You learn what to do and what not to do.
- [Interviewer] So back
to that first night
that you were working in the street.
- Hmmm.
- [Interviewer] Do you
remember that night?
- Yes, I do,
I remember it as if
just happened yesterday,
the guy we ended up meeting
each other that night
and I thought he wanted
to be my boyfriend, right?
So I went and I chill with
him at his family's house.
And he was like, "Have you
ever sold that before?"
And I was like, "What
do you mean by that?"
He was like, you know, "Like
you could get paid for it
"but let me test the product
first to see (Laughing)
"how much it's worth."
And I'm thinking he's joking, right?
So we messing around and then he's like,
"All right, seriously, we
(indistinct) go to Fig right now."
And I was like, "Okay, well call me crazy.
"I thought it was better.
"I'm out here messing
around with me and for free
"why not get a dollar for it?"
So he told me,
"Okay you're not supposed
to date black people,
"you're not supposed to get in cars
"with these license plates,
"you're not supposed to do this,
"not supposed to"
He gave me a whole rundown.
And I'm like sheep, wow.
First mistake I made was jumping
in the car with a black man.
(Laughing)
And I found out the reason was
because 9 times out of
10 they're pimps, right?
So, I jumped in the car,
every dollar that I made
it's just rules to this game.
So every dollar that I
made, he took my money,
he took my cell phone,
he called the dude that I was
messing with, let them know.
Yeah, she was out of pocket.
I'm taking everything.
And she got to pay me.
I was like, "Damn, this
is how this works."
(Laughing)
Like I have no say in none of it.
I just went with it.
Eventually, the more I stayed in the game
the more I got more of the game
and I was able to start doing things
on my own and it made
my game a lot tighter.
And it made me a lot wiser listening
to other females stories,
and the things that they been through.
It kinda made me stronger.
- [Interviewer] Had you
been arrested for it?
- Yes, Lynwood knows me personally.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry.
- I said Lynwood County
Jail knows me personally.
(Laughing)
Which is sad and unfortunate, but yes.
- [Interviewer] So how did you
end up down here on Skid Row?
- Ooh, I ended up down here
on Skid Row because I
had hit my rock bottom.
I was with the love of my life
who had just been arrested,
and not too long before that happened,
I had had all three of my
children taken away from me.
So I had already felt
like I was a little empty.
So to have the person that
helped me get through this stuff
get taken away from me.
It kind tore me down,
which led me to do drugs.
I was popping ecstasy pills,
I was doing Coke,
I was doing crystal.
The only thing I'm never tried
in this world is heroin
and crack and acid.
But I was doing everything,
and I ended up losing places.
I had to stay,
and I ended up coming down here.
Which I met my mom, which was no help.
'Cause every time like,
I mean she'll throw a dollar
or 2 every now and again.
But actually say that she genuinely cares
they wanna talk to me
and figure out the things
that I'm going through.
No, I never felt like
she wanted to do that.
But, I came down here and I
started to get to know people
like genuinely caring
about who these people are
and what do they have to offer.
Because there's a lesson
in everybody that we meet
whether you take the lesson
or leave it, it's up to you.
So I met this guy down here and I met him
through my mother and he was
like a really good friend.
We connected on levels
that I can't even explain.
Like conversation-wise he never came at me
disrespectfully, like I really felt
like it was something special about him.
So I gave him the time of
day, like just to be friends.
And one day we decided
to take that friendship
a little further than what it was.
And I feel like that was the worst mistake
that I could have made downtown.
I got pregnant by this guy.
I started talking to the
love of my life for this guy.
Like, it felt like I could
have a piece of happiness.
And if I could have that, I was willing
to let go anything that
would stop it from unfolding.
So I stopped talking to a lot of men.
I stopped talking to the
person who I felt God made
for me just to see where things
would go with this person.
I ended up finding out a couple
of weeks ago that I was pregnant.
I told the guy, he said
whatever you decide to do
I got your back, no matter.
So I decided to keep my child
'cause it's just not something
that I wanted to get rid of.
I've been through that before
and it's something very painful
that no woman I feel should
ever have to go through.
So we both decided, "Okay,
this is what we gonna do."
So he asked me, "well, what
do we need to do to make sure
"that we don't bring our child
into this world in a tent?".
So we hustled and the
whole time I'm thinking
we were building this life and we got
these beautiful things, when
unfold and occur in our lives,
when this whole time I was the only person
in this relationship, like
I really felt like I had
everything that I wanted
without the value of a dollar.
And I lived in a tent,
but it was taken from me
because he decided to wanna
mess around with other women.
I only found out because of
the fact that he paid my mom.
Dope, do not say nothing
to me about this woman.
And it was really painful
because I really gave
my all to this person.
And he just really took my heart
after me telling him, "If you feel
"like you're gonna hurt
me, please just walk away."
And he did not the guts to just walk away.
- [Interviewer] And the other gentlemen
that you were involved with,
- Yes.
- What happened with him?
- He's actually still in prison right now.
And I feel so bad because, if
he was free there's nothing
in this world that I couldn't
have gotten from him.
And I felt like I turned my back on him
in the time that he needed
me the most for a piece
of happiness that I would never receive.
- [Interviewer] So how far
along is your pregnancy?
- I haven't even been to the doctor yet.
- [Interviewer] So fairly new.
- But I can't be no more than two months.
- [Interviewer] And
what's he in prison for?
- Possession
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- 26.
- [Interviewer] 26, and
you were working Figueroa
you did that for how long?
- Oh, I did it when I
was 18 for about a year,
then I stopped for six years
after I had my kids, but then life hit me
where my 9-5 wasn't supportive enough
of three kids.
In the world we live in the
economy is very expensive,
so wasn't enough.
So it led me back to the streets.
And I've been in the streets since then.
- [Interviewer] (Indistinct)
- Hmm, honestly on a good day.
I'd probably bring like 4 in
the day and maybe 4 at night.
If I did a double shift
or if I just wanted to just
get some stuff out the way
like four 3 was maybe the
lowest I would ever bring.
- [Interviewer] Ad did you
ever get any bad experiences
with the guys you picked up?
- [Ke'] Very many,
(indistinct) one in particular.
I had a guy who was pushing his car
in the middle of the streets, right?
And me I'm just a genuine person,
I like to see the good
in everybody just because I like to think
that everybody has some
type of good in him.
So he's pushing his car in
the middle of the streets.
He's like, "Hey, can you help me?
"I need you to just push it
"so I can get a jumpstart."
So like, "Okay, sure,
"let's push your car off
the middle of the street
"so you won't get it hit."
He would push the car to the side.
He's like, "Okay, well, you
know, I want to date you."
So I get in the car with
him after we get it started
we pull around the corner
and the guy's like,
"Okay one rule about the
game that we never do.
"We don't provide any services
without receiving a dollar."
For some reason, he would
not give me the dollars.
And I kept telling him, "Okay sir,
"well I'm not doing anything
unless you give me the dollars."
So he pulls a bottle
from underneath the seat
and like he's finna crack me
in the head with the bottle,
"You gonna do this or I'm finna hit you."
So I had a pepper spray
on the side of my hip
and I took the pepper spray out.
This is my first time
ever having experience
with a pepper spray.
So it was kind of funny.
So I sprayed the pepper spray
not knowing we're in a
car that is sealed off.
I never been around pepper spray before.
So I'm thinking, "Okay,
I spray him in the face
"he gonna get off of me."
I sprayed the pepper spray,
we both started coughing.
I said, "What the fuck?
"I didn't get it on me."
And me my eyes was watering,
my nose was running.
He takes off running
down the street crying.
He left his car.
Me I take off running the other way.
My eyes is just running
,my nose is running.
I'm looking for anybody for help.
Then I run into another
guy he wants to date.
But then when we date, I get
the pepper spray on the condom,
so now I'm burning down here.
I was like, "Okay, listen, I'm done.
"I need to go now(indistinct)
"It's over, it's a wrap."
That was one of the crazy experiences
I've experienced on Figueroa.
- [Interviewer] You've ever get raped,
beaten up stuff like that?
- No, I've almost got robbed before.
- [Interviewer] I bet.
- Yeah, no, actually I take
that back when I first started
in 2012, there was this
guy out here, right?
He would run around
and pretend like he was a police officer.
And I do believe I seen on the news,
he got arrested, but he
would go around and pretend
like he was a police officer,
making girls do things.
Oh, I know you got warrants.
And so he would make them create
ex he did it to me before,
"Oh, come with me."
I never done any of day in my life.
But that day that man made me do it.
Because I was so in fear
that I was gonna go to jail.
He's like, "I'm gonna give you a pass,
"if we go around the corner, we do this."
I cried the whole time.
And eventually he let me go.
I seen him driving down
the street a couple
of weeks later and he
told me to get in the car.
He said, anytime I come and
get you just get in the car
and you won't go to jail.
I'll let them know not to bother you.
Eventually a woman found
out that it was a fake
and she told, and that man was arrested.
I seen it on the news after
I had left that lifestyle.
And it made me feel so
good because it's like
it's already a burden on us
as women that we have do this.
And then the fact that
people judge and look
at us a certain type of
way, because of the hustle
that we have, it's kinda hard.
It's kinda really messed up,
'cause you don't know why we ended up here
or what we're doing what
the purposes is for,
is not because we like
it or because we love it.
Maybe is the only source
of income that we know of.
But a lot of people take
that as an advantage.
"Oh, they're just whores,
"they have no respect, we don't need
"to show them any respect."
We don't need to show them any type
of like respectful conversation.
That's not cool, 'cause
at the end of the day,
we're still human beings.
Whether we decide to
hustle with the rock side
or with the gifts and the abilities
that God blessed us with,
we have to survive just
like everybody else.
- [Interviewer] Was
giving up their lifestyle
what brought you down to Skid Row?
- Yes, when I left the lifestyle,
I ended up on Skid Row
because I can't tolerate no more.
- [Interviewer] So you went
from South Central to Skid Row?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Which is a big step down.
- Yes, a huge step down
(Laughing)
this I tell people all the time,
I'm bougie ghetto, these (indistinct).
I never knew of like, when
I first got down here...
- [Interviewer] There's
no tents down (indistinct)
- There's no tents ,South central
the first day I got down
here, I see my mom in a tent.
I see a bed,
I see everything else.
I said, "What the fuck?
'Why are you so comfortable in this tent?
And it took for me to have to
go through it, to understand.
- [Interviewer] There are thing people
that watch my channel don't
understand the difference
between South Central and Skid Row.
They think there're similar
and the same thing.
The girls in Figueroa dress beautifully,
they have great nails,
they have braces to fix their teeth,
they have nice cars.
- Yes we don't have any
of those things here.
- [Interviewer] I don't wanna
give too much information,
but some of the girls are
driving Mercedes Benz's
and all kinds of...
And then Skid Row is where
people don't have anything.
- No.
- [Interviewer] They
don't have bank accounts,
they don't have money in their pockets,
they don't have shoes,
they don't have anything.
Very different.
- Yes, very much so different.
There's no similarities.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- There's no similarities.
The only thing that you
may see that's similar,
you may can run into somebody that...
These drugs and prostitution book places?
- That you didn't get assigned from...
(Laughing)
He didn't get home from
but there's very different
because these women down here
and these people down here
don't have it much to give
versus the people like the women
on Fig will get more
than the women downtown.
- [Interviewer] By Multitudes.
- A long Jack.
- [Interviewer] Would
cost you $20 here is...
- Maybe $150 there.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Is a huge difference.
- And is sad because it's
like, these are humans too.
- [Interviewer] When you were
a kid, did you have dreams
of doing something with
your life other than this?
- Yes, I've always had a dream
of owning my own hair salon
but having like a little twist to it.
I wanted to call it a piece
of quiet that a parent can't find.
'Cause we have a lot of
single parents out here
that can't like really do things
for themselves because they
always have their children
or they don't have time
for a sitter or anything.
So I wanted to create this business
to where people can come and still unwind
and have that quiet time
that they need as adults
while their children are
downstairs being cared for.
So a peace of mind that
a parent can't find.
- [Interviewer] Do you
feel like all these years
on the street has changed you somehow?
- Yes, has made me a lot
stronger and a lot wiser.
Without the streets, I
probably wouldn't be here.
I've met a lot of mothers in the streets
and what I mean by that is a
woman that I never even known
before I've met down, before
I came down here will come
to me and ask me if I ate,
asked me if I need anything.
It's a lot of people like that,
you will meet on the streets
versus someone that's sitting
at your table expecting a plate.
You will find downtown.
- [Interviewer] What are
you doing for money now?
- Right now I'm actually
just taking it day by day.
If it comes, it comes, If
it doesn't, it doesn't.
- [Interviewer] Are you
back to work in the streets
dating guys?
- No, because I'm pregnant.
Self-respect I couldn't do that.
Well, I serve every now and again.
Yes I will.
- [Interviewer] You
say serve meaning what?
- I was (indistinct)
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see.
- If push come to the show
but I receive everything that I need
without the value of a
dollar every day, every day.
- [Interviewer] You get depressing times?
- Yes I do.
- [Interviewer] What
aspect of all this life
gets you down the most?
- The fact that all three of my children
are not with me anymore.
Like those were my shadows.
I couldn't even go to the
bathroom without them.
So to look back and not hear
mom, at least a million times
in one sentence, it really
tears me up because like
they are my everything.
When I can't find a piece of
happiness, I can always look
at them and find it and know
that they won't judge me.
I just wished that at one
point in time, I can actually
have us all back in the same house.
But if I can say something
to them, I will let them know
that I'm trying hard to
get back to home every day.
I try, it's a battle and it's hard
because I miss him so much.
I do like kids.
They can get a bit irritating at times
but that's just their job.
But the moment that a
parent doesn't get to
enjoy that moment anymore,
or to hear your kids fighting
or to see them riding
bikes or stuff like that
it really hurts when you are a
rural parent, it hurts a lot.
Like I don't get to roll
over and see my kids.
I put them in their own beds
and wake up at 12 o'clock
in the morning and see somebody laying
on my neck or somebody by my foot.
Like, it's really hard.
And it hurts.
- [Interviewer] And you
lost them for what reason?
- I couldn't take care of them anymore.
I had no place for us to live.
And me as a parent, I couldn't
take my kids through that.
Me, I'm not stable myself.
I didn't want my kids to go through this.
Living in tents, running the
streets, doing all that stuff.
A lot of people would say
I gave up, but I didn't.
I just seem better for my kids.
And it wasn't with me at this moment.
So I let them live with their dad.
I still have access to
phone calls, visits.
They just physically don't
live in a home with me anymore.
And every day I wake up,
I pray and I fight hard.
Whatever it is I need to
do to get back to them.
I'm trying to do, anything.
No child deserves to grow
up without their parents.
I grew up without mine
and it gives you questions
that no child should ever question.
Does my mom love me?
Was I not good enough?
I don't ever want my
kids to experience that.
Never, 'cause I did as a kid.
Waking up in the middle of the
night and not seeing my mom.
I want to break the cycle.
I want to be the mom that came back.
- [Interviewer] Okay, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- No problem.
- [Interviewer] I hope
you get your kids back.
- I hope so too, thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.